and simultaneously check the king and  attack the rook  we have it what let's go back to the  place cameras  no no no no wesley oh he's laughing  david what are you thinking he's missed  it that's what's happened he's just  blundered he paid knight takes pawn  check  and jordan we thought had set up this  amazing trick  forgot it and that's why wesley went yes  i got away with it i'm speechless both  sides blunted we pointed out that trick  that's the only idea behind jordan's  last move  but wesley fell into it jordan didn't  see it and  a moment of mutual blindness there both  sides missing this  elementary trap this elementary tactic  wow obviously wesley has seen it but has  jordan realized  unless he's got the player's cameras on  i don't think he would have realized  he's got a poker face he's realized  david i can tell by that long blink  maybe like maybe he had the camera on